I'm going to show you some stunning
video here propagandist Sean Hannity and
radical repugnant reactionary Republican
congresswoman Lauren bobert got into it
last night on Fox News Sean Hannity
increasingly seems sick of this
contingent of Maga that is
um holding up what could be Republicans
picking a speaker and getting everybody
sworn in and moving forward this is
really good this is the self-destructive
nature
of this party that is unable to govern
that doesn't care about policy that is
obsessed with cultural issues and going
anti-woke and all of this nonsense this
came to a head last night when Lauren
bobert appeared with Sean Hannity and
Hannity went right after her and I have
to say Hannity makes some statistically
good points here and I'll explain in a
moment take a look at this you said
complimentary things about President
Trump needs to tell Kevin McCarthy that
sir you do not sir it's time to withdraw
let me turn the tables congresswoman
Kevin McCarthy has 202 three votes your
side has 20. so if I'm going to use your
words and your methodology and your math
uh isn't it time for you to pack it in
in your side to pack it in considering
he has over 200 and you have 20. now
this is strictly speaking true Hannity
is completely correct if you want to
talk about who's being stubborn or
obstinate or holding this up despite not
having the numbers on their hands it is
a sort of tyranny of this minority of
the Republican Party most of the
Republican party is United but the rules
are the rules but the frustration that
Hannity is experiencing because this is
becoming a clown show is well placed
Sean I understand the frustration I
promise you but I'm frustrated you
didn't answer my question and we are
hearing we are hearing frustrated who
are still voting with Kevin McCarthy do
not answering my question of what we're
doing and they're cheering us on so
there are more for us than are against
us and they are waiting for Kevin to
keep
um
certainly frustrated by I'm frustrated
by you not answering a direct question
you said to president Trump the best you
said earlier today that President Trump
needs to tell Kevin McCarthy you don't
have the votes can I finish candidate to
elect it can I finish the house you
don't have the votes and it's time to
withdraw he has 203 your side has 20.
why is it time for him to withdraw and
not you when he has so many more votes
well Sean he needs 218 and he does not
have 218. we've been trying out in
private as you said for months but Kevin
McCarthy didn't even want to listen to
us until his disappointing midterms we
all want a
yeah so Sean Hannity making a perfectly
fine point it is also completely okay
for a republican who doesn't want Kevin
McCarthy to be speaker not to vote for
him but they need to understand the
consequences that's for them to figure
out then Lauren bobert says maybe I
should nominate Donald Trump tomorrow
and at this point Hannity just says what
you're turning this into a game show at
this point is your final choice for
speaker and if you can't get more than
let's say 30 votes will you follow your
own advice uh that you were asking
Donald Trump and withdrawal
there are certainly names that are being
floated around and hey maybe I should
nominate president Donald J Trump
tomorrow but Sean I I did watch your
show last it's a game show like we're
going to pick on this Motion
Picture Jim Jordan one day Donald's the
other day Trump the next day this motion
to vacate because Hannity is actually
correct in assessing the cartoonish and
childish nature of some elements of this
and this kept going
well not Sean I will not withdraw our
apps were were not Petty of Kevin
McCarthy they were not self-serving we
simply were asking for commitments on
what the American people want to see
they want to see a vote on term limits a
vote on the Texas border plan to secure
the southern border congresswoman we
asked for a vote on a budget that
actually
imagine imagine
a Congress that stops 30 people
supporting you right and we are going to
get the right speakers if you only have
30 to be clear you will not withdraw
it's gonna be a beautiful number but
you're telling Kevin McCarthy and the
and the 203 people that support him to
withdraw because they don't have 218.
that's what you're saying
look it's obvious by tonight's most
motion to adjourn that Kevin McCarthy
and his supporters are already getting
voter fatigue and I asked you a simple
question congresswoman I I she's not
going to answer it and uh Sean Hannity
is right to point out that she's not
answering it Sean Hannity is no better
right I don't want Sean Hannity in
charge of the house any more than I want
Lauren bobert in charge of the house but
the important thing that is of interest
to us here is that this is really really
bad for them now it's also bad for the
country let's take it in two parts later
I'll tell you why this is so bad for the
country and why it's a national security
risk that's the the that that's one
component in terms of the Republican
party this undermines their unity and
cohesion in a literal sense Democrats
are completely United saying we want
Hakeem Jeffries we're all behind Hakeem
Jeffries and you guys are running a
clown show on the Republican side the
Republicans are divided they look
disorganized they're it's Byron Donald's
and then it's Jim Jordan and then maybe
Beau bear wants Trump or whatever so
this will damage their reputation it
will make it less likely they achieve
their goals if and when they finally
select the speaker which I think is
great their goals are horrible I don't
want them to achieve their goals it
distracts from issues presumably they
would want to be working on it diverts
time and energy away from things they
want to be doing which is great I don't
want them doing the things they want to
do it can lead to a really prolonged
period of uncertainty and instability
and that is where it starts to become a
national concern and we'll talk about
that a little bit later and then as far
as the atmosphere within their party
it's getting extraordinarily toxic and
again I'm saying why it's bad for them I
I want it to be bad for them
but the atmosphere there relationships
trust between members oh it's we're
going to support Jordan and Donald and
this that the other thing and hopefully
it will lead to a prolonged power
struggle once this is done and I'm
guessing we've got another day or two of
this I don't know but I could be wrong I
thought we'd have a speaker on Tuesday
this could lead to a continued power
struggle over the next two years which
is great and then lastly
if they finally get a speaker under
these types of circumstances it will be
a speaker whose credibility and
Authority are not going to be solid it
is a very different thing to say we all
want Hakeem Jeffries Hakeem Jeffries is
the speaker the authority and
credibility of Jeffries is untainted
versus we had six eight twelve votes
shifting around support for alternatives
to McCarthy we eventually acquiesce if
that's what happens that hurts The
credibility and authority of the speaker
which again is bad for them so I hope
all of these things happen Hannity seems
to recognize that this is the way the
ball is increasingly rolling I'm sure
many of you will have questions about
this issue and others during our
upcoming viewer Town Hall it is
Wednesday January 11th at 6 PM Eastern
on our Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord it will be streaming live
everyone is invited to participate
members on our website will get Priority
Access to me on the Wednesday Town Hall
you can of course sign up at
joinpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is zipx
nicotine toothpicks zipx brings you a
convenient alternative to smoking and
vaping and The Vape clouds the ashtrays
the thing in your lip that people can
see I've seen that around this is an
easier and less messy way to curb the
cravings and you can use zipx just about
anywhere zipx is available in six
flavors with two or three milligram
strength the nicotine and the flavor are
long lasting and zipix has helped
countless people kick the bad habits and
they are bad habits zipx toothpicks are
FDA registered their customer service is
second to none it is one of the most
cost effective Alternatives also check
out their B12 and caffeine toothpicks
see for yourself why so many people have
switched to zipx 2 toothpicks you can
only get zipx online go to
zipxtoothpix.com and get 10 off with the
code Pacman the link is down below